you have V ramaswami who seems to be
fading we know in businesses and in
politics when things get tight say
goodbye to the advertising he will tell
you that it just hasn't been effective
so he's taking everything off the
airwaves but it's probably something
more to it the Swami has lost all
momentum the best thing about January is
it may be the last month we actually
have to deal with the
ramaswami the leftwing media
hyperventilating frothing at the mouth
at the idea of V's demise the man
igniting all this wild speculation joins
us now from the campaign Trail in Iowa
the ramas Swami so let's get this
cleared up right out the gate V does the
liberal media have a reason to be this
excited no they don't sorry to
disappoint him actually I'm not sorry to
disappoint them I'm actually thrilled to
disappoint them we're going this to the
very end I expect we're going to be
successful but Pete the thing about me
is I'm like unlike other candidates I've
been a businessman I've run businesses
before I understand when something
actually makes sense and when it doesn't
so when advertising rates are spiking
for everybody else you've got $200
million close to that been spent by the
campaigns and their super backs on TV
ads that's not the place to spend it
instead we're going Grassroots bottom up
I've done the full grassly I've done
more stops in Iowa than than probably
many of the other candidates combined
and we're doubling and tripling down on
our spending in a much more targeted way
that's going to deliver you mark my
words on this a surprise at the Iowa
caucus on January 15th I think we're
going to shock the world actually and so
I'm running this campaign in the same
way that I would run a company with an
actual IQ and an actual brain not taken
for a ride by political consultants and
I think that's going to lead us to
ultimately success
here V can you hang a number on what
Shock the World means I mean I've heard
you say that before Iowa's going to be a
big surprise in your mind what does that
mean I love where we're sitting right
now Pete where the mainstream media has
got our expectations low hanging me in
fourth place I think if you take where
the mainstream media's polling narrative
is of having me just in the high single
digits in Iowa we're going to shatter
that and I'm going to leave the rest to
January 15th I think we have a good shot
at winning the Iowa caucus and if you
look at the poll numbers right now I
know that would tell a different story
but it's because many of our supporters
in this campaign they're not ped these
are younger people people who have not
traditionally participated in the caucus
but who are inspire fired by a leader
from the different generation from the
Next Generation with an actual vision of
what it means to be an American not just
criticizing Biden that's old that's
tired that's yesterday but to stand for
actually our own alternative Vision
that's something that's bringing new
people into this movement a good clue on
that Pete is this is 40% of our donors
are first time ever donors to the GOP
that number is 2% for other Republican
candidates so that gives you a sense for
how different this campaign is that's
what we're going to need to win the
general election in Landslide which I'm
confident I'll deliver and that's going
to start with the major surprise in Iowa
on January 15th and I think being a
businessman coming in from the outside
to this world of politics has helped me
call the bluff on a little bit of what
these standard political Consultants do
it's like an assembly line they just put
candidates on I'm not going to be on
somebody else's assembly line we're
making independent decisions and I think
we're going to get the dues paying off
for that on January
15th
but the big one looming in the
background which everyone knows is the
overwhelming front runner of of Donald
Trump who remains polling ahead in Iowa
and V earlier today we saw Michigan
reject an attempt to remove Trump from
the ballot there now you've made some
waves recently when you announced plans
to remove yourself from Colorado's
ballot following that ruling and you
urged your fellow GOP competitors to do
the same but it appears they're not game
for that Governor D santis said it was
quote just playing into the left's hands
and refused to to join you what do you
make of the governor's point you've
repeatedly sort of stood behind the
targeting of trump when they have not uh
would you remove yourself from every
ballot that Trump's disqualified from
should this trend
continue I think this is blatant
election interference in the GOP Primary
by the left and I think one way
Republicans can protect ourselves and
that's why I've led the way in doing it
is by saying that any state that removes
Donald Trump from the ballot none of us
should be on the ballot because that
then takes States like Colorado out of
the GOP Primary which actually stops
them from engaging in this kind of
election interference so Pete I'm a
Problem Solver if there's a problem
presented to us I believe in solving the
problem I also believe in being a leader
and not letting others lead the way if
I'm going to be a follower I'm sad to
see that danis and Haley and Chris
Christie haven't followed that they're
focused on collecting some microscopic
number of delegates instead of standing
for the actual Integrity of our election
but my job isn't to manage them I'm
going to lead this country with the same
Integrity I'm leading this campaign we
got to be guided by principle not
short-term political interest and in the
long run I actually think that is going
to be the winning strategy and I think
next year there's going to be a lot of
unexpected things that play out in 2024
if you w follow where this road ends my
concern is they're not going to let
certain candidates like Donald Trump get
to the finish line and I think it's
really important that we play ahead of
the curve to understand and not fall
into the traps that the other side is
laying for us so I'm going to do my part
to stand for the Integrity of this GOP
Primary but at the same time we need an
America First candidate to lead us to
the next level I believe I'm that
candidate it's going to take somebody
from the Next Generation to do this with
fresh legs and I'm ready to lead the
way well V you're raising expectations
in Iowa and you've disappointed all of
the leftwing media especially uh
Christian Welker tonight V thank you hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else